Why don't you shop on Amazon?
What's the deal?
Sure, so I just find it a little inconvenient.
I'm someone that likes to see the product I'm gonna get before I go and buy it.
So, I think I like that connection that you still have in-store where you can see it.
You know what it's gonna be.
You know what it's gonna look like.
You try it on and then you purchase it.
I'm also not a fan of the logistics.
So, for me in Brooklyn, I do have some difficulty getting packages...
...so it's actually even more of a hassle to order from Amazon...
...'cause I end up going to UPS or FedEx to go pick it up several days later.
So, it doesn't necessarily get dropped off on your doorstep is what you're saying.
Yeah, exactly.
Do you use Amazon competitors or you just prefer to shop in stores?
I think I just prefer to shop in stores.